hi everyone Sal here with my
three-year-old son Azad and we're
excited to announce the launch of Kahn
Academy kids which is designed to take
students like us odd ages two to five to
become lifelong learners hi friends
welcome to my room kids love this
program because it's really fun friendly
characters like our narrator Cody Baer
welcome to Kahn Academy kids interact
with them throughout the learning
experience and we've combined tasks like
math and reading with activities like
drawing and storytelling we really think
parents and teachers are going to love
Khan Academy kids because it's aligned
with important standards like the Common
Core and the head starts learning
outcomes framework there are thousands
of activities and original books in the
program Khan Academy kids also promotes
social-emotional development through
topics like empathy and sharing and
what's more we've partnered with super
simple songs bellwether Media and
National Geographic young explorer
magazine to provide learning materials
kids will love Khan Academy kids is a
free mobile app available in the App
Store and in beta for Google Play and
Amazon download today about the joyful
learning begins
hi everyone Sal here I'm here to
announce hi everyone I'm here with my
son Azad who's three years old to
announce the launch of Khan Academy kids
which is designed aged 2 to 5 ready to
become learners for life you see it loud
and funny download today and let the
joyful learning begin how they do this
in movies